nicolas vidal merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors abstention
record poussée des verts multiples
défaites de la république en marche
qu'est ce que vous retenez en premier
après ces municipales en plus une chose
simple c'est de ne prendre la démocratie
à mon sens et il s'est même le le
ferment pour mois de l'année surrection
silencieuse quand on a pratiquement de
60% d'abstention je crois qu'il faut se
poser les bonnes questions
pour moi c'est le dernier stade une
démocratie un kit en train de
s'effondrer alors qu'on le sait des
municipales
c'est vraiment ce dernier bastion local
de la démocratie et moi je trouve ça
très très très préoccupant c'est
historique c'est du jamais vu
c'est même très inquiétant et finalement
j'ai quand même un peu l'impression que
notre classe politique dans son ensemble
sans faire de généralité mais quand même
est en train de déchirer selon bon en
mots ce qui fait nation aujourd'hui et
on a congédié en somme ce qui constitue
le pacte républicain
alors aucune grande ville pour la
république en marche
à part le havre avec le premier ministre
edouard philippe on peut le préciser qui
se présentait sans étiquette comment est
ce que vous comprenez ce pari manqué
finalement du parti présidentiel
alors moi je pense que c'est une déroute
mais c'est une déroute attendu très
sincèrement alors on peut c'est une
rouge une fessée une déculottée on
choisira le terme qui vous convient
concrètement on peut citer agnès buzyn
marlène schiappa à l'espagne hier une
hache-- et gabriel attaques qui ont
piteusement quitter les municipales mais
très sincèrement moi je crois que manuel
macro alors voir arriver un peu
discordante ans il n'a que faire des
municipales le terrain des manuels macro
c'est l'union européenne c'est le libre
échange et la mondialisation c'est
surtout bruxelles
et puis à emmanuel macron on peut le
répéter est ce qu'il ya eu un ancrage
local un jour manioc macro pardon il n'a
jamais été élu aux municipales il ya
deux fuites étaient présents de la
république donc je crois et rappelez
vous lier le traitement qu emmanuel
macron a fait au maire des débuts de son
mandat
donc il attendait cette déroute qui
attendait cette défaite après on peut
ergoter finalement en disant que les
résultats sont contrastés on a vu tous
les ténors suis pas surprise appelée les
ténors de l'arène
hier soir sur les plateaux nous
expliquer que finalement c'était ça
contrastée mais je crois finalement mois
emmanuel macron il n'a pas besoin
d'ancrage local
vous savez quand on gouverne par
abonnement
quand on a finalement une assemblée
dévolu à sa politique
je crois que manuel de maquereau ou
comme disait jacques chirac de façon peu
triviale servir plus bouger une semble
sans toucher l'autre voilà alors ce que
ce que vous nous dites nicolas vidal au
fond c'est que à deux ans de l'élection
présidentielle ce scrutin local n'est
pas vraiment un indicateur pour la
république en marche
non parce qu'une nouvelle fois je prends
du manuel macro ils regrettent par bella
prowse périphériques en rappelez vous
les jv joint rappelez-vous le grand
débat
rappelez vous une nouvelle fois le
traitement fait aux mères pendant deux
ans et demi moi je crois que manuel
bakwa il regarde pas du tout vers la
france périphérique vous ce mot rappelé
france périphérique est toujours là qui
est toujours en demande de quatre jours
des revendications canton et paupérisée
et ils n'ont je crois que c'est vraiment
son angle mort
emmanuel macron concrètement après on
pourrait on pas qu'on va pas rapidement
nuit référendum qui pourrait mettre en
place en 2021 suite à la convention
citoyenne sur le climat mais ceci est
une vasque une mascarade démocratique
référendum sur l'écologie avec trois
quatre propositions
c'est sincèrement c'est une espèce de
pis-aller pour faire croire aux gens
qu'ils ont ils ont encore la destinée de
leur pays entre leurs mains très
sincèrement pourrait prendre parce
qu'ils sont franchement non je pense que
manuel macron il est le ses yeux port
vers bruxelles et non pas vers le
territoire français alors vous parler de
la france périphérique comme des
territoires oubliés on a une énorme
poussée des écologistes lors de ces
élections municipales c'est l'une des
informations
un vote vert focaliser finalement dans
les grandes villes est moins dans ces
zones rurales et périurbaines comment
est ce que vous le comprenez alors moi
je le comprends très simplement c'est
peut-être trop simple même je vais dire
déjà c'est une vaguelette écologistes et
la crème 60% d'abstention pour quand
même le savoir et puis moi cette
composition sociologique finalement elle
se et se dédit elle a expliqué qu'elle
peut s'expliquer par don avec une classe
on va dire qu'on appelle vulgairement
les bonbons les bobos qui ont fort
pouvoir d'achat qui se sont délocalisés
qui ont quitté les grandes villes où
paris plus exactement ils sont allés
dans ces vilains on l'a vu strasbourg
lyon marseille
toutes ces villes là du moins et qui se
sont mis à l'ouest aussi et qui ont voté
mais ils ont initialement une taille
puisque ont très peu de gens vont voter
cet électorat là c'est mobilisent
et est allé voter donc on a l'impression
pour moi c'est une écologie fantasmes et
jeudi par l'écologie pas important je
dis simplement que c'est une poussée je
dirais ce qu'elle me pousser quand même
un peu timide le dévers et je crois
qu'il faut jamais jamais jamais oublier
la tension qui est pour moi le point
central crucial et qui est extrêmement
quittant de ces français qui ont qui
n'ont plus du tout confiance à la parole
politique et une nouvelle fois les
municipales c'était un bastion look avec
traitement important la démocratie et si
ce verrou saute on ne sait pas très bien
ce qui va se passer derrière
alors pour conclure est ce que
finalement c'est le thème de l'écologie
qui va pouvoir répondre à l'attenté de
tous ces français qui n'ont pas voté
notamment hier aux municipales selon
vous comme ce sont les grands enjeux des
grands enjeux l'enjeu est majeur ça va
être l'économie on peut parler
l'écologie emmanuel macron donner un
gage jeu mais emmanuel macron peut-être
métro projet de loi l'écocide descossy
d'un rappel c'est l'espèce de fumeurs
contre l'écologie pour l'écologie mais
il ya des traités de libre échange qui
avaient été signés dont emmanuel macron
j'attends de lui sur l'écologie
effectivement qu'ils revoient les
traités de libre échange et je pense pas
pour répondre plus précisément votre
question olivier que l'écologie seront
grands thèmes tout le monde et écologie
/ les c'est d'avoir une tête meilleur de
livres mieux plus apaisée plus de façon
plus intéressante mais concrètement
aujourd'hui et d'épreuves économiques
énormes en france et je suis pas sûr que
les français sont de suite tourné vers
leur frigo vous savez la fin du mois
tous cas été porté par les diligences
qui ne sont pas reliés par les soignants
également donc je ne crois pas que les
grands enjeux aujourd'hui une majorité
de français sur l'écologie mais
justement l'économie et la démocratie
merci beaucoup nicolas vidal d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le directeur de la publication
de publication de putsch médias